it's beginning to look very like that i
have to say that overnight and into the
early part of today it has been absolute
chaos here um the paratroopers were
holding their ground but they the
i mean thousands upon thousands of
people had come to the gate not sure why
such a large number are allowed to pass
by the taliban maybe they had stopped
manning their checkpoint it's difficult
to know but there were huge numbers
and they'd got over the barricades that
had been built it's calmed down a little
now they've been able to regain uh
control i mean they're not going to get
overrun per se but they're trying to
actually make a process work and with
the number of people that are there it
just simply can't work because people
can't get who have the right to come in
can't get to the front of the queue we
know they've had to fire shots in the
air and flash bangs which are
not dangerous but very scary and the
reason they do that is so that they can
have a second to move forward and
actually push the crowds back a little
way but as as one soldier was saying to
me you know it works a couple of times
after a while everyone knows they're not
going to shoot them so they end up it's
a bit uh you know it's upsetting but it
doesn't push them back so it has been
fairly chaotic
this camp is now really full of people
is an awful lot just to say i'm not
showing those pictures we've been asked
not to because amongst all the people
here are intelligence assets people have
been very linked to the british
government and to the british military
and you don't know who you're filming
there's loads of families here as well
so it's
we're not showing those pictures but i
can just assure you uh everywhere you go
there are large families i mean hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds if not
thousands of children as well and
they're the ones who are going being
processed they'll go through the process
and they'll get on the planes but
you know if if the chaos gets so bad
they can't actually get the convoys from
here through to the airport because
there's too many people on the road and
so they get suspended and they have to
have to wait until they can get control
so it's been very very difficult uh for
the soldiers it's funny actually though
you you see them though i mean they're
only young lads but they're playing with
the kids they're being very very helpful
i mean this is the parachute regime you
have something of a reputation it's it's
it's been quite amazing to watch outside
further down the street reports of
bodies either shot or crushed other
gates particularly the united states
gate which is known as the north gate is
absolutely chock-a-block with people and
thousands of
foreign nationals trying to get into the
uh rallying points by which they could
get into the flight just simply can't
get through and that's uh
because the taliban aren't stopping
people necessarily but they're allowing
lots of people who have no chance of
getting on these planes and so it's just
basically utter chaos in stark contrast
to the center of town though i have to
say we are hearing reports it's one of
these ceremonies with people um
gathering and unfurling the afghan flag
rather than the taliban white flag and
we understand that um that has been
broken up with the taliban firing into
the air which this is the second city
now to have done that which is
interesting is they you know are people
going to say after all this time you
know we don't want you um you can only
rule us for so long um with the gun but
that's a long way down the road at the
moment the focus the international
community is trying to get all these
people out but it's it's really really
difficult
um we heard from i don't know if you saw
stewart yesterday we heard from the head
of the army on this program saying that
the taliban are a group of country boys
and they are to be given the opportunity
to prove themselves you've come face to
face with him over the last few days he
says there's no evidence that they are
behaving inappropriately towards women
or indeed towards others uh in kabul
what's your personal experience
[Music]
well
i've also met the taliban a number of
times over many years um i think it's
fair to say that in the centre of town
when you get to the sort of the
government areas particularly when i say
the government the taliban government
areas things are calm they're out on the
streets and they're not they don't
appear to be hassling
people in a great way it's not the same
here i mean i've been looking at the
taliban and down the street they they
just haven't changed their spots
whatsoever particularly the group that's
right next to us here the haqqani group
they're absolute killers and they're
really nasty and there's nothing
nothing to suggest to be that they've
changed at all
the senior level may have but i don't
believe that the country boys who were
pretty nasty bunch at the best of times
have suddenly decided that they're all
going to be enlightened i just simply
don't believe it i'm not quite sure why
anyone thinks that would be the case
because we do know where they have taken
control of cities that uh men sorry
women and girls have been stopped from
going to university and to school we
know they've been told to go home we
know that people aren't being allowed to
teach so while it might not be as
repressive as it was 20 years ago
they've only just started i mean it's
only a few days as remarkable as it
seems it was only sunday and here we are
so to say that we've been able to gauge
what the taliban is actually like
nowadays i think is well frankly absurd